while 2020 will surely be remembered for
the coronavirus pandemic which is far
from over
restrictions and lockdowns have had a
huge impact on the younger generation
how have they dealt with it and how has
it changed their lives
as the sun rose on saturday the police
moved in
hundreds of party goers were id'd and
fined for breaching france's coronavirus
restrictions
in the cavernous warehouses near the
city of ren the party
was finally over
the police moved in to restore public
order
first officers secured the area in an
operation
that went off largely without incident
we then issued a number of citations to
people
found to be in violation of the law
earlier the rave had still been in full
swing
around 2500 mostly young people had
gathered on new year's eve
defying police efforts to stop the event
[Music]
a the situation got out of hand very
quickly
three officers were injured and so i
made the decision to withdraw our forces
and while this ran the risk of letting
the situation get even worse
removing police from the scene allowed
them to pursue a strategy of containment
with the police holding back the party
continued for a second
night the organizers defended their
decision to stage the event
i think there was a real desire to come
together
most of us are in our twenties and we
feel we're losing our youth in this
pandemic
[Music]
and many of us are also struggling
against depression
france has the highest number of coveted
19 cases in western europe
to contain the virus bars and
restaurants have been closed
and an 8pm curfew is being extended to
many parts of the country
we knew the risk but we wanted to come
together and party
the whole world of culture is shut down
since the crisis began
we had to come and support the
organizers
fearing a super spreader event
authorities have urged everyone who
attended
to self-isolate when they get home our
reporters talked to four young people
living
right here in berlin if i think of 2020
i think of
geschloss
[Music]
a lot of my work travels
with teaching and performing so
since corona happened it cancelled
almost all of it
the point of where i was really
down to the i think it was just
i am in the last straw of my bank
account
i really didn't have any means to pay
for the next
rent or to have money for my
you know for my groceries and at some
point
i really just worked my body
and i was just here by myself playing
music and i was dancing and i was
letting go
i was letting all of my emotions out
[Music]
lived
we're joined now by mia pavalchak a 14
year old high school student
here in berlin mias thanks so much for
joining us here on dw really appreciate
you making the time
uh you're a teenager of course and a
high school student
this is a time in your life when you
ought to not only be expanding your mind
at school
but also just having fun what has the
past year been like for you
um i think it has been quite challenging
but i started realizing and appreciating
things more
in this year than the past year yes
what would you say was i'm sorry were
you were you still talking
no what would you say was the single
biggest biggest challenge you faced
um the biggest challenge i faced
in the pandemic was probably school and
holding up my grades and everything yes
how was that different because school is
always challenging for kids
how was that different during the
pandemic as
as compared to any other time
um before the pandemic we were in school
and when germany started locking down
what i missed especially was the
learning atmosphere and i couldn't
really concentrate and
i found it quite hard dealing with all
the assignments that we had and
everything
you know when i was your age you know
one of the things that i always thought
about was what i wanted to do this year
or where i wanted to be the next year
how did the pandemic change that for you
was there anything that you really
wanted to achieve
in 2020 that you just weren't able to do
i wanted to visit my family in malaysia
um however this was not possible
and that made me really really sad
because we normally visited my family
every single year
but yeah tell me more about how the
pandemic has actually changed your
perspective
or your outlook on life is there
anything that maybe you took granted
before that
you've come to really appreciate
what i definitely took for granted was
physical touch with all my friends
and other people i definitely missed
that like just hugging someone
or holding hands with someone or
just going out without masks or
something
there's so many people out there mia who
are nodding emphatically just listening
to you really appreciate your time this
morning
mia pavel check thank you
thank you
you